[Music]  all right there he is man  the man himself belly firing up the  the heater hope that [ __ ] works we got  hot water  yeah and now he's gonna do the uh the  furnace next to it we're gonna fire that  up make sure we got some heat  now that we're gonna use it  it's hot as balls in here  oh there you go [ __ ]  oh [ __ ] fellas  we're turning that [ __ ] off because it's  88 degrees in the smart castle right now  ballet was part of your visual comedy  troupe schmods  and henry hudson 1988  state county municipal offenders data  system that's where it all started  everybody  hi boys  that's where it all started everybody me  belly and smitty  rocking it old school doing comedy skits  now we're doing it in the smart castle  check it out thanks  [Music]  you